you now to a briefing it's happening
live uh in Tel Aviv from the Israeli
Health authorities about the captives
the Israeli captives who are released on
Friday opportunity to be part of this
process to have those children coming
home and we hope that the rest will be
coming home soon I'm delighted to be
part of this
process
as I said the children are in a very
good physical condition a large number
of them are in a very good condition but
collectively speaking they are in a very
good physical condition they have been
subjected to medical examination and I
believe that we are not worried at all
once they have been
examined I also believe that this will
be coming in in the coming
days many of them wish to go back home
we have prepared to
them
uh accommodations in order to be
emotionally recover and also to
physically recover and I we believe in a
very few days they will be able to go
back
home yes they have spoken to us they
have told emotional stories
uh fathers and mothers also talk to them
the children also spoke to us we all
shared these stories this is really
emotional it is very difficult to listen
it's is very difficult to describe the
emotions that we were overwhelmed with
uh yesterday evening um four boys and
girls three mothers and one Speaking In
arrived to schider Children's Medical
Center H we were very exciting from the
first moment uh we saw um the kids and
their parents the hugs and the crying
and it was very very exciting for all of
us H they're in good condition H and
they are surrounded by our
multidisiplinary
teams social workers psychologist nurses
and uh doctor
they are surrounded by the family
friends and um it was um I think the
most exciting evening that I had since I
started my career and uh we hope to see
them all back and uh to see them in good
condition yes
please H they told us uh some of their
experience we are listening we're not uh
ask a lot of question but they're
telling us our their stories and we're
listening and we're exciting with them
sometimes trying with them but I can't
share these
stories they're going to stay for uh the
next few days they ask toh stay here
because they very very they feel here
very uh
surrounded and we had very good
atmosphere calm
atmosphere in our hospital and I think
that it is going to take some few
days know something about they went to
sleep maybe around 4 or 5:00 in the
morning and they slept for maybe three
or four hours they're very exciting all
of us so they didn't sleep very well but
I think it will be better in the next
few days thank you thank you very
much